Замість неврологічного відділення - інфекційний госпіталь.
Із захистом доводиться імпровізувати.
Це наше ноу-хау. Це додатковий ступінь захисту.
Обробляється щогодини. Це сліди дезінфекційного розчину.
49-річна Алла Влащук - лікарка-невропатолог, завідувачка відділенням 4-ї київської лікарні.
Нам пояснюють правила безпеки. Ходити в таких костюмах
можна лише сюди - в зону, помічену зеленим. У червону - заборонено.
Туди не можна! Мені теж. Мені так само в цьому одязі туди не можна.
Це не захисний костюм, в якому я маю право йти у червону зону.
Тут працюють 26 медиків. Роботи в них додається з кожним днем.
Україна мало не щодня б'є рекорди за кількістю нових випадків COVID-19.
Відділення майже заповнене.
Тут перебувають наразі приблизно 35 хворих на COVID.
У приміщенні задушливо. Лікарі виходять від хворих мокрі від поту.
Дехто жартує, що завдяки такій "сауні" бодай схуднути можна.
А якщо серйозно, то стресу, зізнаються, значно побільшало.
Невропатологам довелося в стислі терміни перекваліфікуватися з лікування,
приміром, інсультних хворих на порятунок коронавірусних.
У лежачих інсультних хворих раніше також були пневмонії.
Ми лікували. Але ця пневмонія дуже атипова. Ми вчилися, читали,
дивилися, як в інших країнах це роблять.
Так і ми знайшли свою схему,  відповідно до протоколів.
Важкувато. Часу на "розкачку" було обмаль.
4 години роботи в червоній - коронавірусній - зоні.
Тоді 4 години в зеленій. Обіцяні державою 300% доплати за ризики вже отримують, кажуть медики.
Разом з доплатою від київської мерії зарплата медсестри тут
становить не менше 12 тисяч гривень. Медики стверджують, що
поки забезпечені й усіма необхідними засобами захисту.
За п’ять місяців епідемії держава більш-менш налагодила постачання
спецодягу для медпрацівників. Аптечні склади 4-ї лікарні заповнені.
У нас на сьогодні 33 000 засобів індивідуального захисту, повних комплектів.
Я не можу сказати точно, що нам цього вистачить чітко...
Все залежить від кількості пацієнтів.
Якщо буде нова хвиля, це означатиме збільшення в 3-4-5 разів.
Ми чудово розуміємо, що тоді, звичайно, має якесь рішення ухвалюватися.
Друга хвиля епідемії не за горами, переконані лікарі.
Медзаклади можуть дуже швидко знову опинитися в ситуації,
коли не вистачатиме індивідуальних засобів захисту, як це було на початку березня - в квітні,
кажуть у благодійному фонді "Пацієнти України". Їм регулярно надходять звернення від медиків,
що бракує того чи іншого захисту. І чим далі від Києва, тим ситуація гірша.
На сьогодні понад 70% лікарень у країні загалом та в Києві і області зокрема
забезпечені цими засобами на місяць та довше.
Але це не означає, що ми вирішили цю проблему.
Ми вирішили її станом на сьогодні. А за місяць ситуація може змінитися,
і плану поставок від держави на осінь ми, на жаль, ще не маємо.
І я сумніваюся, що держава його взагалі має.
А для того, щоб тримати ситуацію на цьому рівні, ми маємо розуміти,
скільки таких засобів захисту надійде до лікарні у жовтні, в листопаді, в грудні.
Але цього розуміння, на жаль, ні в кого немає.
У міністерстві охорони здоров'я України на запит DW
про наявність відповідної стратегії поки не відповіли.
Відомство має реалізувати задання від Офісу президента
щодо формування державного резерву засобів індивідуального захисту
хоча б на тримісячний термін. Також досі багато питань до тестувань
і вчасного виявлення інфікованих.
У нас міністерство дуже пишається тим, що ми в рази збільшили кількість тестувань.
Це правда. Навесні нічого не робили, а зараз ми робимо  в рази більше.
Але все ж таки ми залишаємося на останньому місці в Європі
щодо кількості протестованих людей! І це дуже критично насправді.
"Пацієнти України" не виключають також перебоїв із ліками,
мовляв, державні закупівлі не встигають за епідемією. Крім того,
деяким хворим на коронавірус можуть бути необхідні ліки,
які не внесені в державний коронавірусний протокол лікування.
Родичі пацієнтів розповідають DW про величезні суми - 15-19 тисяч гривень,
які витратили на лікування та тестування.
Юлія, яка два дні тому вийшла з лікарні після коронавірусу, також на це нарікає.
Найдешевший тест, який ви можете зробити, - ПЦР з носа, -
в ДНК- лабораторії коштує 715 грн. з людини.
Далеко не кожна людина в Києві і в Україні може собі це дозволити,
тому тестів не роблять.
Лікарі 4-ї лікарні застерігають, що симптоми вірусу змінилися.
Це не обов’язково кашель. Це може бути діарея, нудота, просто нежить.
Може взагалі не бути помітних симптомів, а в людини вже двобічна пневмонія.
Розумієте, це дуже важко. Важко морально і фізично. Це не той грип…
Усі чомусь вважають, що це нежить, кашель. Це далеко не так.
Це геть різний перебіг хвороби. Більш важкий.
У деяких пацієнтів сильно виражений перебіг хвороби, коли людина задихається і усвідомлює це.
Це важко. Передусім для самого пацієнта.
Лікарка з 30-річним медичним стажем закликає українців не нехтувати правилами захисту,
не вважати, що "моя хата скраю" і "мене вірус не візьме".
Лише так можна сповільнити розвиток епідемії.
Алла Влащук пропонує і нашій знімальній групі не легковажити і пройти дезінфекцію на прощання.
Ми йдемо... обробляючи, як мінімум, мікрофон, а потім камеру.
Зважаючи на нові антирекорди коронавірусної статистики,
медики і "Пацієнти України" закликають уряд активніше інформувати населення
про необхідність дотримання правил особистої гігієни,
носіння захисних масок в громадських місцях,
дотримання соціальної дистанції, а в разі проявів симптомів або контакту з хворим -
про важливість самоізоляції, адже у світі
це зарекомендувало себе як дієвий важіль боротьби з епідемією.